first a dentist
now a doctor is also being accused of
illegal lion hunting in Zimbabwe yes
folks here's my question
whatever happened to golf yes they used
to play golf doctors right now as
lawyers that enough murdering
not of murder he's ten other running
around killer hunting clubs are
scrambling to put more murder in God to
keep up for ya geesh Donald Trump of
course in the news Donald Trump has
fired a campaign adviser for posting
racist remarks on Facebook yeah isn't
that shocking Donald Trump has a
campaign adviser wanting to be President
arch like jobs gonna be no that that's
not good for democracy yeah you smile
live here I'm gonna have four years of
just blip every night hey the president
in the new Donald Trump said there will
not be another black president for a
while because President Obama is not
doing a good job yeah yeah of course by
that standard there won't be another
white president for at least a hundred
years
that's my Trump just look like you ate a
lemon and fire something there's a rumor
out there that the CEO of Starbucks
might run for president in fact yeah in
fact he opened up his first campaign
headquarters and another one right
across the street I had to say that
quickly before you wrote the ending on
your own yeah yeah we know the
International Olympic Committee has
officially officially recognized
Ultimate Frisbee as an Olympic sport the
news the news was greeted with
excitement by thousands of guys named
Chad guys named Chad everywhere and all
their jerseys Chad yeah dad all those
people's little girls that start
training to be a gymnast at one yeah
finding out that I'm gonna get a medal
too I do this in the park but I just got
a little angry letters from Chad now
dear mr. O'Brien
I think it went probably ate a minute
what am I do all right angry letter
probably me it could probably need dear
dude yep
dear dude dude not cool bro
the fast food chain in and out we all
love in and out in fast food chain in
and outs being sued for allegedly
putting meth in someone's milkshake yeah
on the bright side employee productivity
is up eight hundred percent
[Applause]
in Hong Kong that's right I said in Hong
Kong in Hong Kong a woman was sent to
prison for assaulting a police officer
with her breasts yeah police officer is
demanding an apology and that she do it
again I don't even understand how that I
mean I understand got Technic right all
right yeah it's probably some martial
arts thing shots with the
you